votre histoire est très rare je dirais
même qu'elle est exceptionnelle
jusqu'où peut-on remonter le temps
j'y vais un meurtre un autre dans le
parc n la seconde victime a été trouvée
près de son immeuble bord austin était
là au moment des deux meurtres vos
empreintes digitales ont été trouvés sur
la bourde de la victime c'est impossible
qu'est ce que c'est exactement
il s'agit là d'un fragment
d'espace-temps est-ce que tu enquête sur
la sphère où tu essayes de te convaincre
qu'il n'est pas suspect
la piste est formé à un endroit où ont
eu lieu
3d pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes tous
mouillés hier qu'il pleuvait
on a deux meurtres contre toi
lâche la perdre ce discours
il ya certaines choses qui ne peuvent
être ni annuler ni réparer